بالمجموعة الشمسية
عطارد الزهرة
الأرض والمريخ
المشتري وزحل
أورانوس ونبتون
ندور نحن الكل
عُطَارِدْ أَصْغَرُ كَوْكَبْ
لِلْشَمْسِ اَنَا اَنَا أَقْرَبْ
صَخْرِيٌّ يا أَصْحَابِي
مِنْ سُرْعَتِي تَعْجَبْ
أَنَا أَلْمَعُ إِسْمِي الزُهَرَةْ
أنا سَاخِنَةٌ مُنْصَهِرَةْ
شَمْسِي تُشْرِقُ مِنْ غَرْبٍ
تَوْأَمُ لِلأَرْضِ الخَضِرَةْ
الأرض كوكب صخري
بسطحي انهار تجري
أنسب كوكب للعيش
وأدور وحولي قمري
المِرْيِخْ الكَوْكَبُ الأَحْمَرْ
صَخْرِيْ لي قَمَرَيْنْ
أنا أُشْبِهُ أُخْتِي الأَرْضْ
بِسُهُولٍ وبَرَاكِينْ
بالمجموعة الشمسية
عطارد الزهرة
الأرض والمريخ
المشتري وزحل
أورانوس ونبتون
ندور نحن الكل
المُشْتَرَى أنا الأَكْبَرْ
ومَجَالِي لاَ يُقْهَرْ
غَازِيٌّ أَنا أَنا الأَسْرَعْ
دَوَرَانِي حَوْلَ المِحْوَرْ
زحل حولي حلقات
وجميل الهيئة غازي
لي عشرات الأقمار
وأدور بسرعة وقوي
أُورَانُوسْ وأنا الأَبْرَدْ
وأَدُورُ عَلَى جَنْبِي
غَازِيٌّ لِي حَلَقَاتْ
وَغُلاَفٌ مِنْ سُحُبِ
وأنا أُدْعَى نِبْتُونْ
آَخِرُ كَوْكَبْ وبَعِيدْ
أَبْدُو لَوْنِي اَزْرَقْ
مِنْ غَازَاتٍ وجَلِيدْ
بالمجموعة الشمسية
عطارد الزهرة
الأرض والمريخ
المشتري وزحل
أورانوس ونبتون
ندور نحن الكل